l'histoire est parfois à vendre c'est
vrai à berlin par exemple 10 novembre
dernier vous en souvenez sûrement le mur
s'ouvre quatre mois plus tard et bien
les marchands du temple ont trouvé là un
moyen de s'enrichir ils font commerce de
morceaux de mur à tel point que celui-ci
est devenu une véritable dentelle
véronique auger pierre emmanuel dalcin
le dieu mercure de la porte de
brandebourg ébahi devant ce mur de
berlin devenu lieu brocante à force d'en
prélever des vous les visiteurs ont
versé des dizaines de trous le mur est
devenu branlant à l'état l'âge on vend
le morceau entre 20 et 200 francs selon
la taille
pas de problème d'approvisionnement un
coup de peinture en guise de graffitis
ont des couples et on lit tout frais on
peut aussi louer marteaux et burins pour
se servir soi même c'est moins cher mais
plus risquées
c'est pas de la tarte à découper 17
femmes
regardez moi je me suis passé il y a les
mercantis il y a aussi les artistes
jacques simon architecte paysager est
venu de paris fixé du gazon pour saab
sur le mur et peindre une fresque sur
chaque bord le mur qu est devenu heures
et victoire du vivant l'intérêt de cette
de sculpter enfin de peindre le mur
c'est de leur ramener à la puissance 0
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné plus
plus vous plus vous piochez plus vous
faites de peinture plus le mur va se
réduire et effets uniques effectivement
tomber
le mur transformer aussi en face soir
fraternelle la photo des deux côtés le
petit coup de rouge à l'aise qui en a
bien besoin
quelques heures plus tard les fans abda
pendeloques avait fait des trous dans le
béton mais pas dans le gazon de toute
façon tout cela sera abattu demain à
coup de bulldozer par l'allemagne de
l'est qui vendra les débris pour 600
mille francs
après tout quand on aime on ne compte
pas